peu
[Musique]
pour tous les enfants de par le monde
entier dont les pays sont en guerre plus
souvent qu'en fait je déclare la trêve
pour quelques instants en qualité de
président des moins de 20 ans même si
mon état
la calebasse a deux qui s'appelle
l'amour que j'ai dans le coeur
et même si moh sceptre et un petit haut
j'ai respecté le karma tenant ce nom
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
pour tous les papas
et toutes les haines
tous les gêner
on est tous les prix
pour tenir
ce qui ne voulait
pour les blancs
légende ou bien les noix ou l'ouest ou
le sud
elle est bien
pour tous les
pour que c'est pas simple
cette le concernant sont
non
[Applaudissements]
écoutez
pardon
adieu aux pirates de journal
j'espère d'une
avec tout ça et
pour nous
et que d'un sujet très court on a
en premier
il appelle tous
au journal
ce que je dis
[Musique]
deux jours
non
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]